[Music]
on this wednesday night time is running
out to get people out of afghanistan
fresh evidence of the taliban assaulting
innocent people trying to escape
[Music]
and the threat against female athletes
the situation of our country is very
dangerous why have ottawa's pandemic
briefings been cut off during the
campaign and a coveted surge plus grunge
grudge he was a baby on this famous
nirvana album cover now he's suing the
band
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us the
clock is ticking for four nations
including canada to complete evacuation
flights out of afghanistan the pentagon
estimates there are more than 10 000
afghans at kabul's airport waiting to
get on planes before august 31st the
canadian government says it has already
airlifted 2 700 people out of the
country including a thousand afghans
more flights are on the way today prime
minister justin trudeau says he wants
the international community to put
pressure on the taliban to allow afghans
to safely leave the country if they wish
in the coming days
this phase
will end but there is there's a lot more
work to do that we will continue to do
to keep helping the afghan people
the federal government warns it may not
be able to rescue everyone who is
eligible to come to this country as
redmond shannon reports in our top story
tonight some afghans desperate for
canada's help say canadian forces at the
airport are turning them away
desperate shouts from inside an open
sewer hope is fading for these people
who fear for their lives if they leave
this putrid holding area beside kabul
airport they may never get back in again
violent taliban checkpoints surround the
airport afghan citizens now struggle to
get past global news spoke to a man who
worked with a canadian ngo he says the
taliban beat him wednesday is his eighth
attempt to get into the airport having
been told to go there by the canadian
government a week ago it's difficult to
convince
my family to come along with me and take
the risk for their lives the man says
canadian soldiers have been turning away
non-canadian citizens like him they
don't care about
what documents you show them they just
tell you they keep telling you that
if you got it
if you're holding
canadian passport we will lay in if you
don't please evacuate the area
with an impolite language on wednesday
canada's defense minister reacted to
video suggesting canadian forces were
ignoring the pleas of afghans beside the
airport all these things will be
reviewed and i can but i can assure you
every single canadian armed forces
members who have been there have poured
their heart and soul into bringing as
many afghans to canada
some apparent canadian passport holders
are struggling to leave too although
global news can't verify the
authenticity of the documents these
people are holding
there is a possibility that we're not
going to be able to bring
everyone that we want to when the
airbridge stops the presence of canadian
forces is reportedly decreasing now a
canadian c-17 transporter was headed to
kabul wednesday night ottawa not saying
when the last airlift will take place
our troops on the ground are are
leveraging every possibility that they
can to get as many flights
from ourselves the french government has
already said it will end airlifts
thursday ahead of the expected u.s
withdrawal next tuesday redmond shannon
global news london beyond the desperate
situation at kabul's airport there are
urgent concerns for the well-being of
millions of afghans and the fragile
state of the country's economy some
banks are reopening after being
shuttered for nearly two weeks but it's
unclear if there's any money to take out
atms have long run out of cash the value
of the country's currency the afghani
has plummeted to record lows while food
prices are rising the world food program
says millions of afghans are at risk of
starvation calling it a catastrophe on
top of a catastrophe 40 of the country's
crops were lost last year because of an
ongoing drought the u.n agency warns it
could run out of food supplies by the
end of september
to the kova 19 pandemic the delta
variant fueled wave hitting canada is
only growing over the past seven days
there have been more than 2600 new cases
per day more than 80 percent of these
new cases are among people who are
unvaccinated
and yet today there was no briefing from
the public health agency about these
cases since the federal election was
called there hasn't been a peep on
camera from canada's top doctors global
news has been pushing for answers
abigail beeman is on the campaign trail
with liberal leader justin trudeau and
asked him why this is no longer
happening especially with cases
increasing in the fourth wave
hear me i'm unmuted
while they had regular technical hiccups
pandemic briefings have happened
regularly for the past year and a half
daily in-person updates are really
important but since the election call
not a one though written updates
continue
if we allow a federal election to derail
that job right that that explicit role
that they play
then to me
i i start to question how much politics
is is playing into these releases the
timing of these releases and there's
been no modeling update since july 30th
we relate to people not just to data you
know data will be important but it's
clear that the way we're all built we
actually just want to hear this directly
from the horse's mouth so we asked
justin trudeau about it
we know how important it is to end this
pandemic once and for all that's why
every day
i'm using the opportunity to speak to
canadians to remind them to get
vaccinated are you suggesting that your
comments along the campaign trail about
vaccination are equivalent to briefings
coming from dr tam and dr new and as
well have you or anyone in the prime
minister's office directed back to hold
off on these briefings during the
election
during a democratic event like an
election
our government and our officials
continue to work every single day to
keep canadians safe he didn't answer me
but later said this the public health
agency of canada makes its decisions
about how to best communicate in various
situations public health told global
news the decision on how to communicate
with canadians is quote entirely within
dr teresa tam's purview but like trudeau
sidestepped the question of whether they
had been directed to stop holding
in-person briefings abigail beeman
global news richmond bc
jagmeet singh is in windsor ontario
today where the ndp leader is talking
about taking on the telecom giants for
more affordable cell phone and internet
rates canadians pay some of the highest
fees in the world but singh promises
he'll put a stop to that we're going to
take on the big telco and say you've got
to stop gouging people and the rates
have got to be more affordable we're
going to bring down those rates we can
make it happen
singh says he's committed to working
with regulators to force companies to
reduce prices and cap fees he says under
the ndp plan the average family will
save a thousand dollars
the conservative campaign made a brief
stop in brantford ontario today where
aaron o'toole promised to boost health
care funding if elected pledging 60
billion dollars over the next decade
with a big focus on mental health
services
this will be the largest increase
in federal health spending in a
generation
it will reinforce and secure our public
and universal health system
and it will enable the provinces to
invest in mental health
as the health care priority it is
the conservatives seem to be crossing
over into typical ndp territory in
recent days o'toole has been making a
pitch to unionized workers and as
michael couture reports it's all about
securing a broader base
we will put canadian workers at the
front of the recovery it's time for the
government to stand up for workers and
secure canadians pensions for two
straight days aaron o'toole has tried to
pitch his party as the only one standing
up for workers monday he proposed worker
representation on the board of directors
for federally regulated companies and
tuesday he talked about protecting
pensions
wednesday an even more direct appeal i'm
going to say to all canadian workers
including members of unions i'm going to
fight for your jobs union leaders aren't
buying it our party for the powerful the
rich and the powerful and they're surely
not for the working families let's not
forget that
what did he do when he was a harper
cabinet minister
he supported the two most anti-labor
bills ever to be introduced in this
country
union votes have historically gone to
the ndp this is o'toole's attempt to
broaden his tent
it's a direct appeal to a number of
writings across the country that have
flipped between new democrats and tories
like essex in ontario where the ndp
leader was campaigning tuesday and port
moody called quitlam in bc both justin
trudeau and aaron o'toole don't think
that billionaire should pay their fair
share wednesday in windsor ontario
jagmeet singh tried to differentiate
himself from the tory leader pointing
out o'toole voted against an ndp motion
to tax companies like amazon that made
record profits during the pandemic so he
might say what he wants right now in a
campaign but what did he do when he had
a chance to vote he voted for the
interest of the super rich against
workers that message could resonate here
in hamilton home to the canadian steel
industry it's also home to three ridings
where the incumbents aren't running in
this election meaning those seats could
be hotly contested
robin mike likature reporting tonight
thanks mike and ahead of september 20th
election day global national is
traveling across the country to talk to
you the viewers and the voters that
kicks off tomorrow in bc and today donna
friesen was out preparing hi donna
hey robin i'm in steveston bc today off
and on throughout the campaign i'm going
to be out of the studio and on the road
tomorrow our focus is climate change
which here in bc because of the terrible
heat wave and the devastating fires move
from an abstract issue to a real front
burner issue we'll be traveling to
alberta ontario quebec and nova scotia
and we're going to talk to actual voters
about what matters to them and try to
avoid the experts because we talk to
them a lot no offense but we do so
that's what we're up to in the weeks
ahead
but coming up tonight what air canada is
now requiring from all of its employees
plus the worries about kids going back
to school and covet not going away
[Music]
canada's largest carrier air canada will
require all employees and new hires to
be fully vaccinated against covet 19.
workers must report their vaccination
status as of october 30th air canada
says testing will not be offered as an
alternative kids and teachers across the
country are heading back to school but
the provinces have taken a varied
approach in how classrooms will look in
the fall and whether educators will need
to be vaccinated a new study not yet
published reveals how sending children
back without masks or vaccine mandates
will only fuel the delta variant wave
jamie morocco reports
as kova cases rise calgarian courtney
dillenbeck has some reservations about
sending her kids back into class next
week i don't want my kids to go to
school and get sick alberta has put few
pandemic safety measures in place for
the coming school year instead it's
opted to leave the decision up to
individual boards six-year-old cece says
at least through september she will have
to wear a mask sometimes when you're
sitting down
you don't have to but
otherwise
when you're standing up or anything like
that
you would have to a new pre-print study
out of york university ran multiple
scenarios and found when precautionary
measures were implemented in schools
including masks mandatory vaccinations
and physical distancing the difference
in the total number of cases
in in the fall wave isn't huge just
because
the delta variant is already in
circulation in the community but without
them canada is on a troubling trajectory
it'll just be
insane the number of cases that we'll
get this week british columbia manitoba
and quebec announced mask rules for
certain grades ontario made the decision
three weeks ago but no province has
committed a strict mandatory covet 19
vaccine policy for eligible educators or
students the benefits of vaccines far
outweigh any theoretical or potential
risk for that child
especially with delta surging dylan
beck's kids are too young to get their
vaccines yet so she says she's relying
on teachers to keep them safe i would
feel more comfortable sending my young
kids to school knowing that at least
their
number one adult interaction is
vaccinated researchers at york
university also found approving covid19
vaccines for kids under 12 could have a
big impact on the outcome of this next
wave
when that approval could happen
is still unclear robin jamie morocco in
toronto thanks jamie finding affordable
housing is a struggle for more and more
canadians and it's become a hot button
issue on the campaign trail the three
major parties all have their take on
affordable housing and gaviola explains
what they have to offer and what might
actually help canadians
accusations are flying about housing
affordability on the campaign trail
aaron o'toole would give your landlord a
tax break on selling the building and do
nothing for you we can't afford another
four more years of broken promises from
justin shito it's no surprise this issue
is a hot one in the lead-up to the
federal election what housing prices
have done during the pandemic has defied
expectations average sale prices are up
more than 30 percent in fact since
justin trudeau first took office in 2015
home prices are up nearly 70 percent
that's according to the canadian real
estate association here's a look at what
the big three federal parties are
proposing
the liberals want to build preserve or
repair 1.4 million homes in four years
the conservatives pledge to build one
million in three years and the ndp are
targeting half a million affordable
homes within a decade the liberals and
the ndp want to increase tax credits for
home buyers the tories proposed tweaks
to the mortgage stress test and
insurance requirements to make it easier
to qualify for financing and the ndp
would bring back 30-year terms on
insured mortgages both the liberals and
the conservatives propose a two-year ban
on foreign buyers while the ndp strategy
involves a 20 foreign buyers tax expert
reaction to the platforms is mixed when
it comes to
affordable housing
on the rental side the ndp platform
which focuses almost exclusively on that
is likely
the better of the three the
conservatives have the most
comprehensive overall plan which touches
on many different areas and they have
well thought out detail as to how
they're going to implement these
policies
for politicians the challenge is finding
the sweet spot a plan that improves
affordability for those struggling to
get into the housing market without
derailing the wealth building and
retirement plans of existing homeowners
and gaviola global news toronto
up next the race to protect afghan women
in sports as the taliban takes control
you're watching global national
[Music]
team canada just wrapped up its first
day at the tokyo paralympics and it was
a solid start in her paralympic debut
cyclist keeley shaw nabbed canada's
first bronze medal of the games in the
c4 3 000 meter individual pursuit later
quebec swimmer early rivard won a bronze
during the women's 50 meter freestyle
five years ago in rio she won gold for
the event this is her sixth paralympic
medal
those athletic achievements may now be
out of reach for women in afghanistan
their rights and freedoms are on the
brink of disappearing as the taliban
takes control of the country and like
thousands of others trying to flee women
and girls who play sports will likely
face harsh punishment for simply doing
what they love here's mike armstrong
if the women in this video were
identifiable we wouldn't use it it's
just a bicycle race in 2017 through the
streets of kabul but those streets are
now controlled by the taliban and they
are after women like these
these women are on the hit list of the
taliban now friba rasai was
afghanistan's first ever female olympic
athlete she now lives in vancouver and
runs a non-profit aimed at empowering
afghan women as leaders this week her
work has been about trying to get female
athletes out of the country and to hide
the ones she can't already she says the
taliban has gone to homes summoning
women to sharia courts to have their
character judged because they played
sports
if they
are successfully catching any of those
athletes
they will face severe punishment from
the taliban from lashing to death
penalty
under the taliban women and girls are
banned from sports it's not modest it's
too physical and it's too public there's
been a push this week to get female
athletes out of the country before
they're punished
one of the groups literally pulled out
of the sewage trench at the airport and
put on planes was afghan female soccer
players a flight tuesday carried 75
players officials and relatives flown to
freedom in australia
an evacuation flight to spain carried a
member of the afghan women's wheelchair
basketball team nilofarbeat and her
husband made their way through taliban
checkpoints past beatings and shootings
and spent two days at the airport
staying in afghanistan she says wasn't
an option being a woman in taliban
regime mean nothing
you're not part of the society you're
just the one you can stay at home and
doing nothing
meena assadi competed for afghanistan in
karate for a time she ran a gym in kabul
she says so far the taliban has been
somewhat quiet she doesn't expect them
to stay quiet absolutely no they are
never changed
and they are yeah they are in the same
taliban
this female afghan paralympian made it
out of the country to australia this
week there is hope she may even make it
to japan
in time to compete in her event mike
armstrong global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm robin gill we leave you
tonight with a young hockey player
walking tall
if we shift to the left we'll have you
loose
small steps but big progress ryan
stratznisky was left paralyzed after the
tragic humble broncos bus crash in 2018
but yesterday after three years of
rehabilitation and surgery he tweeted
the video of his first steps with jester
walker ryan says he's still trying to
figure out the best method but can only
get better from here thank you for
watching donna friesen will be back
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]